hello and welcome to video where a man
who knows nothing about comic books
tells you whether comic book movie is
good or bad uh
the batman came out right and it faced
the unique challenge of you know living
in the shadow of christopher nolan's
dark knight trilogy but here's the good
news not only is the batman good even if
i do have problems with it which we will
get to soon but um it manages to step
out of that shadow in even the smallest
ways for example nolan's batman is
typified by you never seeing him come or
leave he's just there but pattinson's
batman has these iconic footsteps that
you always hear before he arrives out of
the shadows i really loved that more
importantly though the batman really
leads into the detective noir side of
batman stories with clues and leads and
interrogations and mysteries and
conspiracies that sort of thing which i
think is fantastic we've never really
had that not to the extent that we get
it in the batman and i think that really
helps it set it apart tonally and
aesthetically and the feel of the story
the film is also unashamedly a comic
book film one of batman's opening lines
is i am vengeance
and the suit is campy and catwoman has
this literal bella clava with little cat
ears and patterns in his brooding and
dark makeup it's just it's just great
it's very comic booky because all of
this means that the batman just feels
different to the films we've had before
you know so it's a detective neo noir
film but is it a good detective neo noir
film
um sometimes you know sometimes it's
clever like for example there's this
clue where it's like you are el rata and
you figure out that eventually it's a
reference to a website and i didn't pick
that which felt dumb but i should have
but again sometimes it treats batman
like a freaking genius for figuring out
the most basic like
fortune cookie riddles
it is at its heart a functional mystery
and it's a fun ride to go on but i'm not
sure that it's the type of mystery where
if i watched it through again i would
pick up on a whole lot of really cool
details you know that gives me that
second viewing experience which to me
is kind of the test of a really good
mystery i did figure out that renewal
this program created by thomas wayne was
probably a bad thing that it wasn't what
people were saying it was like really
early on in the film but that's not
because like it's too obvious it's
because of the cinematic language
tip if anything is on a newspaper or on
the news in the background of a scene
it's never a coincidence it is always
foreshadowing
the real strength of the film is that
the riddler is a fantastic adversary it
constantly feels like he is a threat
that he is in control and that batman
even if he's figuring stuff out is
always a few steps behind
he consistently has the upper hand i did
have to laugh when they said that the
riddler has like 500 followers you know
can you imagine the riddler doing like a
a ray shadow legend sponsorship in the
middle of one of his like murder
broadcasts you know i'll i'll kill this
man just like y'all killed the heroes in
the castle if you click my link down in
the description the batman isn't really
a whodunit story which kind of
disappointed me because i was under the
impression that because the riddler was
wearing a mask that he was going to be
revealed to be someone um
and that never happened and that's fine
it's more a personal thing i don't think
it needed that but i will mention one
gripe that i have with the riddler
despite thinking that he was a fantastic
antagonist
is that i
really don't like um psychopath villains
where their only way of showing that
they are a psychopath is that they will
suddenly explode in anger and yelling
um you know the the only way that they
show that they're unhinged is that they
can't go a full sentence without going
from one decibel to 100. i loved
moriarty from sherlock and he did that
too but it is a little bit cringy and it
happened a little bit too slingshotty
you know too much back and forth uh for
me in the riddler like the riddler was
the most imposing when he was just that
shape on the bridge at the funeral or
when he was just a curser on a computer
screen going have you figured it out yet
there's a silent coolness to that that's
really threatening that makes him feel
in control and i'm more afraid of people
who look like they're in control
and have the upper hand than people who
seem unhinged you know because unhinged
people you can exploit so i wish they
did more of that but this does lead me
on to another massive strength of the
film it is very cohesive everything in
the film fits together wonderfully the
whole mystery and what is uncovered is
intimately tied to batman's ark and his
desire for vengeance and fixing the city
uh as a way of continuing his father's
legacy in a way grappling with what that
means uh who he is as a wayne and who
his father was and in turn that also
really connected to catwoman's arc which
has a lot to do with vengeance as well
bringing these two characters who are on
similar trajectories kind of into a hit
as they evolve in different ways
catwoman and batman both end up in the
exact same moral position they discover
that falcone is responsible for the
death of a loved one the impetus for
their anger and the question is how do
they deal with that and they deal with
it differently there's this symmetry but
also this dichotomy that's that's quite
interesting so the deeper sense that
everything is really connected means
that it felt well thought through and i
think that's great writing i had a
really positive experience with the film
and there was only really one thing that
when i walked away from the theater and
days on am still thinking about that i
didn't really like was the stuff that
happened after they caught the riddler
and they exposed falcone they got him
arrested by the good cops you know
basically it is then revealed that the
riddler inspired his 500 followers to
destroy gotham city by flooding it
biblical style to wipe away the
corruption but this suddenly turned what
was a subtle neo-noir detective mystery
story into a save the city story
and i didn't gel with that vibe as much
that the sudden escalation in the stakes
didn't sit right with me in this film
but also because batman's arc was kind
of meaningfully finished by this point
he chose to not kill falcone to rise
above vengeance and i'm not sure the
stuff that these final beats did for him
really fit you know catwoman had also
finished iraq just in a negative way
because i have a sense that is kind of
her character
there's the scene
at the end after the flooding has
happened where he gets out of flair and
he has a light in the dark and he leads
these people out in a sort of religious
procession almost and then he's seen in
the light helping people onto stretches
it is a little bit funny
it's again it's a little bit of that
campiness uh it's it's weird to watch in
a way
but
i think for me that felt like a batman
ark for the sequel you know the the ark
for this one was him rising above
vengeance and then him grappling with
what he should actually do in the light
rather than in the dark i think sounds
more like a sequel arc that they should
have developed more it just didn't feel
like the natural culmination of the
story for me but who knows maybe i'm
wrong i also just wasn't a big fan of
the sequel bait with the joker in the
prison it's it's just if you want to
give us the joker just do it in the next
film uh i i've never been big on sequel
vade but none of this means i did not
enjoy the film i really did and i
recommend going to watch it if this is
your sort of thing i will also note that
it's aesthetically just beautiful like
my jaw dropped when i saw bruce wayne's
gothic architecture home it is stunning
the whole film
looks gorgeous it's done so well i don't
know who does that sort of thing but
it's beautiful to watch and it looks so
much nicer than in my opinion any of the
mcu films you know the the last thing
that i want to mention is that there is
this one moment where he's escaping the
police and he jumps off a building and
batman just
totals himself on the bridge
look out for it it is really funny it
seems tonally just way off from the rest
of the film it's like slapstick comedy
ah but i also i did love that he got
beat up as well like he's not invincible
in this film which i think is really
cool he's not untouchable anymore
anyways i give batman a b
out of 10
for batman
bye
also a b for bye